he was asked to condemn and denounce the
kkk
as a hateful organization and he
neo-nazis
white supremacists and he would not do
it he had he had about three
opportunities
during during that questioning where he
could have and he deflected he says well
we should talk about antifa and they're
like no i
we want just for our president we would
like for you to say that you're going to
condemn and he knew he couldn't do it
because i feel anyways from that move
that he made and this is my assumption
is that he understands that there is a
large sect of this country
country that votes that believes in
those neo-nazi beliefs
and they're going to vote for him so he
won't say it but instead
he'll deflect and say well what about
this he uses what about isms which is
literally an eight-year-old in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast if you're a first time
listener there's a podcast about
anything and everything genius brain is
a another way of saying that i'm [ __ ]
dumb it is chicken soup for your soul
exactly people people somebody who wrote
they go
uh they go don't you think it's a little
uh self-centered to say that
uh to call your podcast genius oh
another one again
and i'm like you are so stupid i hope
you die
just listen to one episode and you'll
realize this is a podcast of some of the
dumbest people on earth
his brain what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you guys man not you guys another person
come on guys let's get it together all
right well apparently we have to talk
about this
the the [ __ ] the most fire
presidential debate
i've ever seen in my life that [ __ ] was
fascinating you know the thing is um
halfway through watching it
i forgot for a second that this is
reality like this is
this is real this is not some scripted
like sketch
i was like oh holy sh i just felt like
so exhausted at that point like dude
if you had like anxiety it was hard to
get through
because i just wanted somebody to finish
a sentence yeah
just anything right and there was a
moment where they were i wouldn't say
cordial
but there was a point where the
moderator had who's the moderator
against chris wallace chris wallace so
chris wallace
it was funny watching chris wallace
because he was being very cordial at
first too
and at a certain point he had to raise
his voice sir sir mr
president mr president he just couldn't
stop
did you notice he stopped calling him mr
president towards the end it was just
sir yeah he just
didn't have any more respect for this
guy he goes sir sir
sir well i don't know yes sleepy jokes
sleepy joe is the most funniest [ __ ]
moniker for him yeah
to trump's credit that is a pretty funny
nickname um but
it was just you know is it was i said
this on twitter but it was like watching
a petulant child argue with a senile old
grandpa
with a with a responsible adult trying
to you know
prevent it from going off the rails
that's what it was like you know
like two kindergartners fighting over a
lollipop yeah dude i was like holy [ __ ]
look man i i think though that was
trump's strategy
i mean i think it was just to disrupt
the whole thing make sure that um
joe can't really say anything
substantial and
really get a point across and you know i
think joe did find some spots where
he was trying to connect with the you
know american people by looking directly
into the the camera and talking to them
straight up
yeah but trump wasn't having it man he
kept talking over me yeah he wasn't
having it and um
you know what the crazy [ __ ] is there's
actually a committee that exists for
presidential debates
it's called the cpd committee of
presidential debates right
so now they're looking at kind of
changing up the structure
for the debate and one of those changes
are going to be muting the mic
and i'm like okay there's a [ __ ]
commission
why is that not a standard in a debate
that helped out a lot and look they had
that before
they had that before and so i don't
understand why
uh in in more recent debates that that
is not something that's there just give
them the button just go dude
it's [ __ ] 20 20. it's not hard to
have a you know
something in place to to mute the mic of
of the other candidate
um and there's it's not that hard i
think that
they should implement a fact checker
like oh a factor
in real time in real time right so in a
day they don't have the fact checker
doesn't necessarily have to disrupt
the debate it's just more like a pop-up
a pop-up yeah yeah because i even do
this for this podcast i have like fact
check
[ __ ] where i'll say some crazy solutions
why is why
look why is that not a standard in this
day and age
if there's a [ __ ] like what is this
committee doing or this commission doing
like what
what are they doing what are they
regulating what are they because
because the hard part is generally for
you know i forgot what there was a
phrase about statistics it was like
you know what i'm not gonna even
slaughter it i'm gonna put my little
factory bubble there
but it was something along the lines of
like good liars used to take
since like statistics are used by good
liars or some [ __ ] like that right
because the problem that i have with any
type of political debate or anybody who
has uh something that they say uh are
facts and not opinions right
because this podcast is all opinion
based right and you can fact check my
[ __ ] all day and i guarantee you
99 of the time your boy wrong so
you know yeah um because it's based on
my opinions and people can have
their own thought about certain things
but the problem is is that when we start
bringing definitive statistics and
numbers
and the general public doesn't know you
could make anything sound smart
exactly i could literally say like the
problem with this country today is that
there are about
60 of people in this country are
unregistered
immigrants who are criminals and rapists
and literally 90
of people who come to this country have
a criminal history of being a rapist
right this was fact and i could say an
institution and i could say something as
salacious as that yeah
and people hear numbers and statistics
and they immediately believe it as fact
and not to mention something like the
presidential debate should be
held to a higher standard yeah people
are tuning in to get
facts to get an idea look i'm i'm gonna
assume that most people who are tuning
in
um aren't necessarily undecided on who
they're gonna vote for
but there are those people who are
undecided and if they're tuning in to
see
like why does this person deserve my
vote
and they're like you said they're just
throwing out facts i mean
facts yeah um
numbers statistics right and naming
institutions to back up whatever
claim they're making but then there is
no real-time fact checking that's
happening
yeah you could lie through your [ __ ]
t which is what trump was doing
right because it was even a couple of
times i forgot where what
joe biden was saying but he was talking
about the
he was it was it had something to do
with covet numbers right now i could
take those numbers and consider it as
fact
but then because there's no fact check
checking we just have to go by their
words
or afterwards when they're done we have
to double check for ourselves right and
i think that's what they're expecting
the general public to do
but i think that from now what you've
seen on twitter and everything else
nobody really does that right they just
listen to this like for example
um so you know the fires that happened
right it was because
uh it was it started from a lady who uh
did this gender reveal party thing right
or the person who started the gender
reveal party she just did it because
she enjoys parties she likes being very
festive
and if you see a picture of the original
cake that she had it's just busted ass
cake
it's nothing really big right there was
one thing that i saw on twitter i can't
find it anymore
but somebody put up this thing on
twitter and it was the most ridiculous
[ __ ] i've ever heard in my life they
wrote this
they wrote this whole backstory saying
that the person who started the gender
reveal party
the reason why she did it was because
she had multiple miscarriages and before
she could find out the gender of the
baby
the baby would pass away and so they put
that out on twitter
and immediately it became fact nobody
double checked
and so i i remember when i read that i
was like this sounds like a parody or
something right
a little thing so i googled it right and
not a single article could be found and
every article where she's been
interviewed she stated i wish i never
did the gender reveal party because it's
something ridiculous and i'm just
somebody who's very festive who likes to
do fun things
but somebody put that [ __ ] on twitter
and it had a ridiculous amount of
retweets
and so when i did this like i did a vlog
and i just talked about gender reveal
party somebody was calling me an [ __ ]
saying like well you're kind of an
[ __ ] because
gender reveal parties happen because
this lady had multiple miscarriages i'm
like
holy [ __ ] you are so confident enough to
call somebody else out on their [ __ ]
because you read something on
twitter yeah that blew my [ __ ] mind
that's gonna ultimately be the downfall
of like our society man it's just so
much misinformation gets put out there
and it gets spread so easily
speaking of wildfires that's it spreads
like wildfire yeah you know
um and look even in this debate
it was hard to even take away anything
uh
like there was no cohesive point that
was being made because there was so much
nonsense going on right like it was just
unintelligible what they were saying
because it's just interrupting and
there's talking over each other three
why
nobody wanted to see three old white
dudes just trying to argue and talk over
each other you know it's like just
two geriatric [ __ ] arguing about some
dusty ass [ __ ] in their old home
like i just in the old people's home i'm
like yo
shut the f i wanted to be there and just
tell everybody to shut the [ __ ] up
like you shut the [ __ ] up and you shut
the [ __ ] up well joe did say at one
point
you just shut up man yeah that was like
the best part of the debate
somebody finally told this dude just
shut up dude yeah just just
shut up man it almost like i want to say
it's tactical but at the other time i
just think he's just a narcissist like
he is for sure just he can't he can't
not stop being himself for one [ __ ]
second you look at his face
when um joe is talking and he's trying
so hard not to say anything at some
point but as soon as joe says something
negative
he can't handle it yeah he needs a super
100 defensive mode
yeah even if he he defends with uh
just lies he he will try to defend
himself no matter what right because he
doesn't know how to be
in this type of professional setting in
any sense of the way
and people and i don't understand why
people still want to bring this up when
it comes to trump
first of all man i just want to put this
out here people have been trying to
label me as
uh at whatever political party they're
like he's a
is he right-wing i'm whatever the [ __ ]
you know what i mean
i won't even tell you what what what
party i'm registered for because it
really doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah you
know at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter for me because i don't
know enough about politics to usually
really talk about it
i can only see it for what i think it is
right that's why you never hear me talk
about politics because i don't
[ __ ] know yeah so when it comes to
these type of things it's just sometimes
it's hard
to really filter through all the
[ __ ] because i i see this
where i see two guys
well this is what my biggest issue right
now is that every time i see
a tweet about and this is for somebody
who doesn't know what's going on really
um about why we should vote for biden
the major campaign behind him is that we
have to get trump out of office
but if i ask somebody what do you like
about them they go we have to get trump
out of office i'm like so the only
reason why you're going to vote for
biden is because you dislike this person
so much
and i'm not saying that that's um like i
disagree with that but at the same time
it would be nice for me to know
what's so great about biden you know and
that just kind of goes to show like what
weird reality tv show that we're in
right now where a majority of people
don't know the reason why they're voting
they just know that [ __ ] this guy i need
to get him out so we'll just put anybody
in there at this point
you know it's weird i mean but that's
how
kind of uh how much i guess
politics has devolved is that we're at
that point now a reality tv show yeah
where it's
like the guy who's in charge has is so
ridiculous so outrageous
so deceitful that the
kind of the driving force behind you
know joe biden's campaign is
we need to vote this guy out of office
because you have
like a super long list like almost an
infinite list of reasons of why
trump is not fit for a president right i
think
any reasonable logical person can look
at the facts look at the details and be
like yeah
this guy is pretty ridiculous you know
in order to be 100 supportive of him
you either have to be one
blind or ignore the facts right or two
there's certain policies you have
certain policies that you want to see
being brought to the forefront and
that's your agenda
as whatever party you're affiliated with
right
and look there are intelligent people
who are will kind of just say
yeah it's it's all fine and good because
the policies i care about
yeah are are being put in motion you
know
and it's just like dude how can you
ignore everything else about what this
person stands for and what this person
represents when he's supposed to be the
president of the united states now
i'll put it to you like this i have a an
uh
like a substantially older family member
like pretty old
and this person is a hardcore christian
and i'll tell you this this person loves
trump this is a korean person
and the way this person talks about
trump is so odd so in my mind
because she's hardcore christian you
would think that
she wouldn't vote for this person right
because
though he talks about christianity and
faith his actions speak otherwise
um it's completely contradictory exactly
so when i see
some of these churches back up trump and
say he's a man of god
i wonder what that is right and now
religion is becoming involved in this
president well not even now it's always
been involved in this presidential in
the presidential race anyways just
because of the the way this country is
backed and
created or how it started anyways it's
rooted in a lot of like
the protestant religion like
christianity and stuff but when it comes
to
when it comes to that she specifically
loves trump because she says she's
christian
and if we say but he's not christian i'm
talking about she gets livid
and she gets [ __ ] matches don't even
start with me on that [ __ ] but which is
which is so odd because
i'm like how can you deny you're seeing
how he is as a person
yeah this i could say anything i could
say i could be on this mic and say hey
guys let me tell you something it's
really tough having a [ __ ] tennis
dick
you know but unless you see the tip of
it from the start of my pants all the
way out to these short ass red shorts
you don't know if it's true or not yeah
you know yeah
but it's weird is it because i wonder
why people see that just as face value
from
is because just he just said it out loud
because i'm pretty sure
this is joe biden christian too yeah um
oh no i think
why joe biden might be catholic catholic
well he's of the protestant religion
or whatever the christian christian
religion yeah yeah um
look man i think they just christian or
whatever they just
are looking for things to grab at i mean
just because
trump did a photo op in front of a
church holding up a bible makes him a
stand-up christian
you know like i'm surprised he didn't
burn on sight she's [ __ ] nuts yeah
um and it's kind of ridiculous like all
the christian values that are
really um i guess stressed on within the
the
religion this podcast is brought to you
by june b matcha not all matcha is
curated and created the same and june b
matcha stands out above the rest
if your matcha isn't a beautiful shade
of jade green and doesn't have an earthy
smooth taste
then you're definitely not having junebe
matcha is not supposed to be bitter the
caffeine boost and health benefits you
get from it are the best
no caffeine jitters and loaded with
antioxidants to get 10 off your first
order
of tins and packets go to junebeshop.com
that's j-u-n-b-i-shop.com and enter code
geniusbrain to get 10 off your first
order
today get that matcha on what is
trump really doing to uphold those
values or to
to even push those values right um i
mean this guy is what
divorced three times yeah who two three
times at least
you know um he's gonna be raping women
issues
what talks about grabbing women by the
[ __ ] right like
it's like that's the pillar is that how
a conservative christian
talks and thinks you know what i mean
and so so it's like
that's what i'm saying you have to
either one be oblivious to the facts or
ignore the facts if you do know the
facts
that's the only way that you can line up
your agenda
with with a in in uh with a guy like
this supporting a guy like this
otherwise it's it's like
if you're a decent human being um and
and this is not even from a political
standpoint
if you're just a decent human being
let's say no political affiliation you
don't affiliate with the left or the
right
you're just looking at it objectively
you look at kind of like the values that
are considered good
in our society and then you look at a
person like this
how can you say that is somebody that's
presidential
you know because the president
historically
right it's it's somebody that's supposed
to
uh be a man or woman with integrity
with honor who's a role model uh
who basically leads by action
right be intelligent
all of those things that i just
mentioned are without
yeah trump doesn't check the box on any
of those he doesn't have any of those
qualifications
i i think he got into office or why
people liked him was because he quote
unquote wasn't the typical presidential
case yeah yeah
and so that's what they kind of uh fell
in love with i think the
the hard part for me when it when it
came to him coming to office was
knowing his background how many because
they were saying oh he's a businessman
so he's going to run this country like a
business no emotions involved he's just
going to make the right choices right
but that [ __ ] went bankrupt the
gillion times mommy and daddy's money so
yeah i don't understand how that really
works a small loan of a million dollars
from his dad
yeah like how many how many families in
america
can give their child a million dollar
loan a small million dollar loan you
know yeah
so his his i think his perception of
reality is completely skewed
because of the way he grew up privileged
super privileged
um so his head is is just not in the
right place man he doesn't look at
things
the way a normal person looks at looks
at it because he can
yeah he he's never experienced that and
so he doesn't have these
world real worldly experience that's
relevant to being able to
be a compassionate person a relatable
person
and so if his only qualification was
that he's a
quote unquote successful businessman how
has be
how has he been uh running the country
so far yeah
i mean some of these staunchest
supporters of his will say oh he's been
doing a great [ __ ] job
really what what has he done
exactly that makes him um makes it
qualified to say that he's doing a great
job
with the coveted response with the
unemployment creating jobs
right what has he done you know what i'm
saying i think from what i read the
people
from i mean i'm just reading up a few
things i think what people liked
about him was um i think there's a lot
of gung-ho americans that
didn't like the way i don't know
president obama positioned america as a
in term of power in this in in the world
right so for example when
trump did there was a lot of people
they're like yo this guy's gonna get us
[ __ ] killed like for example with the
whole north korea situation
um i was reading a couple of things
online where there's a lot of people who
supported that because they were like
trump is saying that america isn't a
bunch of [ __ ]
and he was saying like yo go ahead throw
your [ __ ]
missiles at us missile man or rocket man
and i'll show you how dope we are
so people liked his position of america
not being a bunch of whims and bowing
down to other countries and kind of
setting america's power as
who we are in this world so that's like
the stuff that people enjoyed about him
um
that i think people still to this day
very much support
i don't know as a as uh like um
gun loving you know red white and blue
american
type of person i could see how that
might be appealing
but in politics yeah right in terms of
world power
diplomacy there's a there's a certain
decorum that's required
there's a certain way to handle these
things and it's not by just
yelling and and flexing on another
country
and tweeting about you know
we'll show you the likes of that you've
never seen before yeah
and he also appealed to a lot of middle
america right which
people i think forget exists or a lot of
racists
yeah it's well i mean we could even talk
about that during the presidential
debate right dude
he was not he could not he was asked to
condemn
and denounce the kkk as a hateful
organization
and neo-nazis white supremacists
and he would not do it he had he had
about three opportunities
during during that questioning where he
could have and he deflected he says well
we should talk about antifa and they're
like no i
we want just for my president we would
like for you to say that you're going to
condemn and he knew he couldn't do it
because i feel anyways from that move
that he made and this is my assumption
is that he understands that there is a
large sect of this country
country that votes that believes in
those neo-nazi beliefs
and they're going to vote for him so he
won't say it but instead
he'll deflect and say well what about
this he uses what about isms which
is literally an eight-year-old tactic
that's all or not all okay a lot of
trump supporters
that just shocked me when he went i was
like oh this is a breeze for trump he's
gonna be like yeah of course like kkk
they're terrible
wouldn't do it i was shocked i was i was
actually shot not only that is he
identified uh you know extreme alt-right
group the proud boys
by name and then he said stand back and
stand by.
he didn't say stan chris wallace his his
questioning said
would you tell him would you condemn and
tell him to stand down yeah that that's
what he said specifically
he said stand back and stand by
and now members of the proud boys took
that
as as a call to arms almost you know and
celebrate it
that we're right i mean like what what
what what is the implication there when
you're saying stand back and stand by it
sounds very militaristic yeah exactly
it's saying stand by for some [ __ ]
if if if we need to call on you stand by
but for now
stand back and stand by though and so
that was like a
[ __ ] softball question you know you
said super softball
knocked that [ __ ] out of the park so it
is not hard to say
like even before chris wallace finishes
the question
you can stop right there yeah of course
i condemn
white supremacists and neo-nazis or any
hate groups
yeah but like you said he had to
transition into
what about antifa though look man to be
fair
i don't identify with a political party
but if there's
any type of extreme groups that inciting
violence or committing acts of violence
whether it's on the left or the right
nobody's with that [ __ ] yeah nobody is
with that [ __ ] that should be condemned
period but if you say that to a trump
supporter
about these hate groups these extreme
uh alt-right groups these neo-nazis
these white supremacists
that are uh causing violence or walking
out in the streets with military gear
and guns you know trying to patrol
what they're doing is wrong they'll say
what about antifa yeah what what about
almost never will you see them
acknowledge that like yeah
that is wrong that shouldn't happen
whereas
for me even though i'm not i i don't
identify with the public
political party yet still i don't uh
support trump
i could say uh if anybody's doing that
[ __ ] on the left side there's there
is an extreme because look the head of
uh
uh fbi right and trump's fbi said antifa
is more of an idea than an actual group
that exists
but i'm sure there are people out there
who take that ideology and act on it
right internalize it and act on it so if
there are people like that
those people are not only wrong but
they're criminals
yeah you know what i'm saying like to
commit acts of violence on people
uh especially in like peaceful protest
setting
look self-defense is a whole different
thing if if there is
rioting and somebody's like coming at
you in a very hostile manner and trying
to attack you
you got to defend yourself that's one
thing to be like
all right we're going to go out there
and cause chaos and
create havoc that that's just like an
anarchist
you know and so that's the thing man
it's like
that's what's so frustrating about the
current climate
like within politics is that all of
these staunch
trump supporters will not be willing
to have an objective conversation on the
situ they're so gung-ho
about everything trump stands for you
know about making america great or
america is great now because of trump
it's like dude what are you what are you
[ __ ] looking at man well now it's
becoming to this point and i think i've
mentioned this before where
a lot of these symbols that we have in
our country that was supposed to be
um an idea of like universal freedom
you know for example like i'll just say
uh to that i'll say like our american
flag
i forgot who i had this conversation
with but it was something along the
lines we were talking about
isn't it funny how the american flag
is now when we look at it me personally
when i see it it reminds me of racism
isn't that weird that how somebody on
the side of they go well [ __ ]
you know black lives matter you know
they're on the opposite of blm and they
wave the american flag
that the american flag is the opposite
of blf
like i don't understand so now it's
becoming convoluted where people are
taking this idea of what america
is uh into something very negative it's
it's weird how
the flag can be waived as this is what
america stands for and sometimes the
people who are waving the american flag
they are being represented of an
ideology that people who want equal
rights for themselves
it's they're saying that we're the
opposite of what you want so it's
becoming all mixed and muddled together
right it has become more about
perception than facts
yeah and it was when i when i talked
about for example like the maga hat back
in the day right
i think what people like to do when they
when they want to argue their point
they want to talk about surface level
things that really are extremely
irrelevant like for example with the
make make america great
again hat right they say well what's
wrong with wearing a maga hat
right like it's just a hat with with
words i want to i want to make america
great again
why can't i feel that way it's never
about the hat
right it's what that hat represents it's
just symbolism it's a symbolism behind
it right because we could talk about
that with
anything if i were to break it down
right we could talk about it with the uh
the the rising sun tat uh the rising sun
if you have a rising sun tattoo on your
arm
right we could just say dude that's just
the sun when the sun rises that's what
it looks like
but that's like a that's like a nazi
symbol to a korean person
right so people won't look at that they
just want to prove their point they go
this
is just a hat yeah things are obviously
just a hat
yeah we could say just to anything to
but but you're completely ignoring what
something might represent exactly
what it does represent it could
represent that to you there's context
there's context to it right and people
just want to ignore that because they
want to be
right and i think that you can wear that
hat and say hey like
i'm wearing this hat because i feel like
america isn't the way that i feel like
it should be
and this is not any offense to you but
this is what it represents to me
but instead the the response is i could
wear whatever the [ __ ] i want [ __ ] you
right and to other people too when they
see that hat they're also not trying to
have a conversation it's like hey do you
think it's a smart idea to wear that hat
and a group of people who are maybe
colored yeah
who feel very uncomfortable with you
wearing that hat
do you mind taking it off right but
people get very extreme they get upset
they get in their emotions they're not
willing to have a conversation
yeah and and again it's it's all based
on perception
and not facts like a lot of these people
aren't educated on things
like for example you know a big thing
ever since trump has been in office is
that
if you disagree and you have like uh
more liberal views on things you're a
communist you're a marxist
like do you even [ __ ] know what that
means yeah it's
just because you don't agree with
uh what a republican candidate or
republican president
is doing and saying and not just as a
republican because he's a [ __ ]
ridiculous dude
right does not mean you're a [ __ ]
communist by default
it's not if you're not this you're
automatically this but
because that idea and kind of that
ideology it just keeps getting spread
like places on twitter
they say it without even understanding
or knowing what it is that they're
saying
oh you don't agree you're a communist
it's a lot of like
things aren't should never just be
considered black and white there's a lot
of identity politics too
so if you go if you disagree like for
example right like if you
let's say um like me like if i say oh i
disagree with
uh certain things that trump wants to do
with this policy right
and they go well you [ __ ] left-wing
nut right i bet you're super [ __ ]
like hold on a second how come i can't
be let's say i'm a republican right
why can't i be a republican that
disagrees with this presidential
candidates who is also a republican with
some of the way that he
that he handles thing and still be a
republican because
policy wise i'm probably a lot more
right wing but socially i'm probably a
little more liberal
and that's just kind of where i lie like
let's just say that's what it is
but the moment that you say something
that disagrees with the party that
you're
that you're that they think that you're
not affiliated with they'll immediately
group you into the other side and
they'll
and they'll basically disregard
everything that you say
because you're either extremely
conservative or you're extremely liberal
why can't i just be an individual that
has an idea about the policies on both
sides exactly
and they don't want to hear it they just
i think people want to create enemies
they want to anchor themselves to
something because they need to be
labeled
yeah i think that's the problem with a
lot of people people people say don't
label me but you [ __ ] can't
live without a label
you cannot live without identifying
yourself to a certain group or something
else and if somebody falls astray from
that idea
you want to group them into something
else without even asking them who they
are as a person
right so i see it constantly all the
time if i
if you or an i or anybody else has an
opinion you only think that if you don't
agree with me
that with this part then you're the
exact opposite of who i want to be or
who i am
and not every topic that you talk about
with somebody should be dealt with like
that
no exactly not talking about like
kidnapping children
yeah you know yeah yeah i do
completely agree man you can be a 100
republican a conservative republican
and still have criticisms against trump
it's but but that's not
that's not what it is now what it is now
is just this mob mentality
it's like you're either with us or
against us yeah yeah you can't be
republican if you
are critical or disagree with what trump
is doing
that doesn't make you a republican then
you're a communist yeah you know
you're a snowflake yeah right you're
snowflake yeah it's crazy to me man
how like how polarized uh
politics have become i mean look man
what the gop
represents now it's it's actually ironic
because if you look at it historically
the uh the democrat is
the democratic party is more like what
the gop party was
historically for most of history and now
gop
the gop has become this like really
left field super skewed um
ridiculous idea party uh with a bunch of
cowards in it
to be frank because a lot of these guys
are just kind of uh backing trump
for let's say certain policies that they
want put up front
right they're not willing to take a
stand and be like
look i can't agree with that yeah that
that is not i mean look there are a
handful of people who have stood up to
it but i i would say most of those
people are cowards men
and you know there's there's a huge part
that people don't even mention which
i think a big part of the responsibility
also lies with media
because media does and you know social
media outlets like facebook and
instagram and twitter that they allow
for a lot of false information to fly
out
there's actually a documentary about uh
the social media
um on netflix i don't know if you got a
chance to see it but it's
basically people who are all involved
with some of the biggest social media
platforms facebook
twitter um your uh what are you
uh tick tock oh no no not tick tock um
snapchat google uh yeah youtube
um and uh what's uh what's the one with
the red logo
uh where you see like a bunch it's like
a curation of different stuff
hold up right it's gonna it's gonna
bother me if i don't if i don't uh
pinterest pinterest i i couldn't
remember for some reason but anyway
it's uh people who were basically
part of maybe the core team or held high
positions in these companies
all coming out to talk about how
dangerous social media has become for
spreading misinformation
um so yeah i completely agree man there
should be some checks and balances in
place for that
but uh going back to the whole the media
being accountable right
yeah here's the thing is there's always
going to be
media outlets that have a certain bias
and the thing is
people will still choose to get their
news and get their information from a
certain media outlet
a media outlet that might be more
aligned with their views and their
values
and their their uh political party right
so
let's say somebody is you know extreme
left or extreme right
like extreme left person's not gonna go
to like an extreme right news outlet or
or
media outlet looking for information
news they're gonna stick to
ones that are more aligned with their
views and same with somebody who's like
extreme right they're gonna look to
extreme
right outlets oh that's what happens on
facebook consistently like i had
i had to have a conversation with
somebody where they were
kind of bringing up they were very upset
on facebook po constantly posting stuff
that
um enraged them about you know left-wing
politics right
and when i message with him on a dm on a
personal thing it's like hey i'm not
saying i agree or disagree with anything
that you're saying
but you sound very angry about stuff
that is information that's constantly
being fed to you
and i screen capped him my facebook
right i was like he's like i don't go on
facebook at all
but just because i live in california
you want to see the stuff that comes up
on my story
it's all liberal left-wing stuff so and
if i picked out a handful of this stuff
it's going to refute every article that
you put out in a video
it will have the same video it'll be by
vox media and then some other stuff
and they'll chop it up in a way that
kind of caters towards what they want to
say in their agenda
so you don't even understand that you're
just a little [ __ ] in this game and
you're being
you're a pawn like people are using you
they're [ __ ] with you emotionally
yeah but but to be fair to be fair there
is misinformation on both sides that's
what i'm saying so
that's what i just said it was they're
gearing it towards their bias right and
so whatever information
right wing outlet that you have is going
to gear towards your right wing bias
and this left side media is going to
guarantee your left foot for sure
so we're not really looking for truth
algorithmically what these companies do
they just look for stuff that you are
specifically going to be interested in
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] about the
truth they don't give a [ __ ] about
unbiased opinions
it's more like what is this what does
this person want to see and how can i
get them to buy more [ __ ]
exactly i mean it's an age of
sensationalism and clickbaits
how much [ __ ] i bought during
quarantine the stuff that i know i for
for a fact i didn't [ __ ] need yeah i
bought this [ __ ] where you could attach
it to your sink
i saw one video it was this person just
had a bunch of spaghetti
and he just dumped the strainer and you
connected
to the side i was like you know what
there are multiple times where i've
washed my dishes and i wanted to get rid
of the stuff and i didn't want to put it
down the drain
i bought that [ __ ] in two seconds yeah
that's crazy i didn't need that stuff
but they knew they know what i
know because they're listening man
they're they're you know what i like
look it
i highly recommend that people watch let
me let me uh
look up the documentary name just to
make sure i believe it was called the
social hack
um but i highly highly recommend
uh that documentary on netflix um
let me see here but you know what i did
find out um
through the whole presidential debate
was oh i'm sorry it's called
the no it's not the great hack [ __ ]
you know what i'll i'll i'll look it up
next time
i'll put it up on here yeah yeah i think
marielle was watching it uh
a week ago or so yeah it's it's really
informative because like i said these
people were inside members of the team
behind these social media companies and
so they give a lot of
insight to why they think it's so
dangerous and why they're actually
taking measures to to counteract that
now they're not part of the companies
anymore
um but i wonder why it's so hard for
people nowadays to have
uh open conversation and and uh and a
willingness to
hear what somebody else has to say um
and i'm not saying that i'm any better
because sometimes when you get heated
about certain subjects sometimes you're
heated
but it is going to take people um
some personal knowledge about themselves
to understand
that number one maybe i'm not as
open-minded as i thought i was maybe i'm
not right all the time
and maybe i should take a second to stop
and listen to what somebody else has to
say
even if you don't agree with them right
because
there's nothing happens when you don't
have empathy when you don't understand
where somebody else is coming from
because
somebody says the things that they say
and they think the way that they do for
a [ __ ] reason right
not to say that they're right or that
they're wrong but in order for you to
kind of
bridge this that weird area
where i see like a that bridge is just
filled with hate
right there has to be some type of
understanding for you guys to meet in
the middle not to say
to to bring somebody over to your side
but to just understand where they're
coming from
because when you start to understand why
they think that way
then you can kind of empathize with them
and allows you to get along with them
cordially absolutely you know and i
don't think a lot of people want to do
that and
it happens a lot with the youth because
i'm thinking about myself when i'm
younger too we're just so emotionally
volatile
and people are [ __ ] using that
against us so
well yeah man that's what these social
media companies are doing
yeah you know um look man having empathy
and compassion isn't a weakness
it isn't it's it's it's just about being
a decent human being man
it's like but the problem is is that
i feel like in this day and age uh
there's a good amount of people uh
throughout the country
where they don't have an open mind and
they're not willing to have an open mind
they're just so uh stuck
in their views and they're unwilling to
compromise on that
it makes it hard to have an open
conversation yeah because
it can come off as an attack to them
or they just want to be right or a mix
of both
whatever the case is it's like if
one person is not willing to have an
open mind for a conversation then the
whole thing falls apart
both parties need to be they both need
to come to the table with an open mind
be willing to have a civil intelligent
conversation
about whatever topic is is is uh the
focus
some some some people too man i feel
like some of y'all just like to argue
just for the sake of arguing
like some some of the stuff that i know
you [ __ ] argue about you don't
know [ __ ] about
you just want to argue with somebody
yeah that's the sad part right and
that's how it is with politics a lot
it's okay to say you don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on with with the political
scene in this country at all
because if you don't know you don't know
right right or or maybe there's only a
limited amount of things you know and
just focus on that then
yeah just leave it there you don't have
to know
like every single thing that's happening
and every single thing that's going on
i remember when uh every [ __ ]
influencer was being
flamed for not speaking up about
politics it's like i don't think they
should
i don't think the guy that uh that
finger [ __ ] himself
with a banana and then throws goop at
his face should do a political campaign
for anybody
i think he should shut the [ __ ] up sit
down and not say [ __ ] yeah that's what i
think and they're like
well and this is the phrase that i hate
the most he goes uh
people love using this phrase and i
think it's one of the most commonly used
phrases that should never be used again
it's
it's better to do something than nothing
at all and that is not true
i disagree with that wholeheartedly it's
better to do nothing if you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing exactly
you know exactly that's a better thing
rather watch and learn
yeah sit listen i mean look god gave us
two years for a reason
yeah and only one of these exactly
that's what i'm saying too and
i'll give you a great example it's like
would you say that about somebody who
has a fire in front of them right
he doesn't know how a fire starts he
doesn't know um what causes it to
combust or any type of chemicals that'll
make it work
he sees a liquid in front of them right
that i gotta light it up yeah
this liquid happens to be 99
gasoline right and he goes this is a
liquid i'm gonna put out that fire
and he does something and [ __ ] light
[ __ ] up and then you look at him say
it's better that he did something than
nothing at all that's not true
that happens i know i'm being a a little
bit hyperbolic but that's what i feel
happens sometimes with people who feel
like they just
need to argue you just want to argue for
the sake of being in a conversation
sometimes you don't need to be in a
conversation where you don't know what's
going on yeah
just shut the [ __ ] up or do what i do
say dumb [ __ ] and make jokes
yeah and just leave it at that or take
the time to educate yourself
to to to read up on it to you know
research it and then develop a view or
an opinion about it
rather than just going into it
completely blind and just saying
something because you feel like it's a
personal attack
on maybe what you uh believe in or what
you
think is right without really having all
the facts right
i'll use a great example right because i
grew up i grew up christian my whole
life my father's a pastor and everything
else right there's people who i know
specifically in this city
i think there's a lot of people who are
atheist or agnostic or whatever
and um they see how i speak and how i
behave and they go
are you a christian and i'm like yeah i
would still say that i'm i'm a christian
and they go well how can you prove that
god exists
i'm not going to sit there and have a
theological debate about the existence
of an omnipotent being that i can't
prove is here
i just say i believe what i believe
because i believe that there's a god and
there's a higher being and they go why
i'm like to be honest with you bro
i don't know you know i just feel like
it is
you know this is how i've been roaming
my whole life and it helps it helps with
my moral compass like it's it's
something that's very therapeutic for me
and i and i
i don't know i believe that there's a
god out there and if you're not okay
with that answer
then it is what it is but i'm not gonna
sit there and try to argue with somebody
about something that i can't prove in
terms of
you know god's existence just because i
feel like i want to argue about
something yeah
you know like i have a pretty strong
rooted faith in
in the christian religion but i'm not
going to get mad when somebody
i'll be even sometimes mocks my religion
because i can't
what am i going to do and what am i
going to say i i can't convince that
person otherwise
i could just especially if they don't
want to be convinced exactly it is what
it is
again it goes back to having a
conversation or entering the
conversation with an open mind
if you're if you're really genuinely
curious about
let's say you know what you're talking
about right now religion right why do
you believe what you believe
but then they're asking that question
genuinely
like they're genuinely inquiring because
they want to know they want to hear it
they want to
think about it that's one thing but then
if you're asking that
without really intending to listen and
just have a bunch of rebuttals in place
then that's not really an open-minded
conversation yeah that person is
literally just arguing for the sake of
arguing yeah just trying to prove a
point
and and i i dislike those people the
most because really what you're trying
to do is make somebody feel bad for
believing the stuff that they believe
look and and things like religion is
obviously a little bit more sensitive
topic too
um and so it it requires even more so
than other conversations for you to keep
an open mind
and and to not be judgmental because
like if you're asking a question about
it
then listen i'm willing to talk about it
but if you're asking just to argue with
me
that's a that's a whole different
approach yeah so
it's a i don't know man it's so tricky
with with some of those sensitive topics
because
you don't know what the real intention
of that person is yeah man
like and to have these conversations are
it's difficult sometimes but i think
that we do need to start teaching people
on how to
how to have these type of conversations
because through uncomfortable situations
like that you do tend to learn a lot
more if you have an open mind
like if you're willing to listen to what
somebody has to say absolutely
because i've been in a lot of those
situations specifically in some in being
in a relationship like
if you have ever been on a long-term
relationship and i always say this too
is that
you you never go into a relationship
learning more about the person that you
do about yourself
because you start to realize sometimes
about the stupid [ __ ] that you do
because you you want to have a healthy
relationship anyways you want to have an
open mind
and have open conversations with the
person that you're with right like
there's a lot of stuff that i started
uncovering about myself being with
mariel that i didn't realize because i
never had to address it
because i was never in these
uncomfortable situations and at first
because i was so adverse to um change
that i it was easy just to blame it on
my partner like oh this happens because
of you
um i can't think of a very specific
example right now but there have been
a lot of aha moments where i was like oh
i wasn't really listening to what she
was saying i just wanted to prove my
point and prove that i was right in this
conversation
yeah look you know look we we all are at
fault with situations like that we've
all done i'm we're [ __ ] human you
know what i mean we're gonna make those
mistakes but
the important thing is is to recognize
those mistakes and try to learn from it
it doesn't mean that you're going to be
impervious to making mistakes again
ever again you're as a human being we
are going to constantly [ __ ] up
but the goal at least is to try to limit
those [ __ ] ups as much as possible by
growing and learning from situations
um and so again going back to like the
whole religion thing too
um for me because most of my life i was
a non-believer and i became a believer
later on in my life
i have that context so when i talk to
somebody
you're a later christian yeah way later
like mid-20s
your parents aren't christian no well
now they are now they are that
see that's an even more of a shock is
they became believers
at 60 years old bro can you believe that
[ __ ] damn that's nuts
at 60 i believe [ __ ] at 60 years old
right to
first of all be old school koreans who
are pretty like
come on at 60 dude you've you've lived
enough life to be pretty set in like
your views and your beliefs and values
but that's that that's how amazing it is
man
i think you're the first korean person
that i met that didn't grow up with like
some type of like judeo-christian
background oh yeah i did it man
um it was it was my own personal journey
with it and so
when i when i talked to non-believers if
the if the conversation
happens to come up or i get asked about
it or whatever
i don't ever approach it from a
standpoint of like trying to impose my
beliefs on somebody
you know i just approach it as a human
being what does that do what the [ __ ]
does that do nothing it accomplishes
literally nothing
i'm not trying to say oh because you're
not a believer you're going
come on man like they're another human
being and if they just want to have a
conversation about it and
it seems like they're they they want to
have um a productive conversation in an
open conversation
i'm more than willing to share my
experience and i can speak on it because
i know how my life was like prior and
after and so i just i just share my
experience with it and like what my
journey was like
uh with that and so i've had
completely um non-judgmental
civil conversations about religion with
people
uh as long as they're receptive to it
and then there's been times where it's
like this because it's like
they don't really want to talk about it
they just want to argue about it you
know
and so it's it's a very different thing
with approach um
i mean i've definitely had my handful of
conversations with people where
especially when it came to religion the
immediate response is for them to call
somebody stupid for believing in
something that
they that isn't tangible you know and at
that point it's like
why can't you know what from here let's
just kick it and chill like
this is not a conversation yeah this is
you trying to make me feel
bad about something that i believe in
that doesn't affect you
yeah it literally doesn't affect you you
could you just gotta chill
exactly exactly why why is it so
important
to you to change my mind about something
yeah you know something that does not
affect you at all uh
something that it doesn't uh hurt you uh
it it does
it it has no negative impact on your
life like this is not something that
should matter to you at
all yeah why why is it so important then
that
who who introduced you to uh
christianity then
i mean look i've been around it my whole
life you know i
most of my friends uh would be christian
like growing up in the church because
they're family
but it nobody really introduced me to it
you know those guys going to hell we
give up like
yeah my friends would try to have
conversations with me about it but it
was
honestly just a very personal journey
for me you know it was a process of like
learning uh going through certain life
experiences
for me to arrive at that destination and
then so
that that's a yeah that's a whole nother
long story in and of itself but
i won't really get too into that but
yeah it was it was my own personal
journey with it and
i came to the conclusion on my own it
wasn't anybody who was really trying to
like
sway me into that direction i remember
high school i was just passing out that
purpose-driven life book
to everybody i was like yo this
[ __ ] going to hell hey bro
you want to read the purpose-driven life
yeah it was funny i was giving people
that book
[ __ ] i didn't read it myself i
never wrote it myself i was like i heard
this book
yeah listen i don't know what this book
is about but i think you should you
should read it
yeah i heard this [ __ ] is tight and i
gave it to a bunch of people i remember
one of my friends i remember you trying
to convert me to christianity i was like
yup and you're still going to hell
no you know you know one thing one thing
that i will say
is um when i when i talk to
non-believers right
the example that i always give is like
something that's pretty universal i feel
like is
look when you let's say are like on the
top of the mountain
watching the sunset off in the distance
between the hills with all the trees you
know you see the sun rays and different
shades of color right you look at that
and you think that's [ __ ] beautiful
right you look at that and think wow
right my my
uh not an argument but my thinking about
that is
is that's innate that's not a learned
thing
you don't learn to to appreciate like
landscape right you don't learn to
appreciate certain things
you just when you see it it strikes a
chord within you right
and my reasoning for it based on my
belief is that
because this world was created for us
for men and women right and so it's
innate in us already to appreciate
what was created for us and so when you
see things like that you can't help
but think wow that is beautiful or wow
that's amazing to have that type of
sentiment and have that type that that
type of reaction so
that's that's always something that i i
i use as an example
uh of like um a simple
explanation for why uh
god exists you know um some people can
can hear that
and and be able to relate to it or other
people might think uh no
i mean i still don't think that you know
that's a reason to
believe that god exists which is
completely fine yeah i'm not imposing
that on you yeah i'm just saying
that's how i think about it you gotta
take them to the cliff and if they don't
believe you just throw them right now
you believe it now [ __ ] and then you go
to hell too
yeah going back to the uh what was it
the debate real quick though yeah um
through it i i did a little bit of
research because when trump mentioned
the proud boys by name
i wasn't really familiar with that group
i didn't know what the proud boys were i
thought they were just saying somebody
was proud i had no idea i was a group
yeah yeah so i mean i knew of them but i
didn't really know anything about them
you know and so i started doing uh a
little bit of research into them
one of the uh original co-founders of
vice
is who started proud boys what yeah he's
no longer with vice
but you have to imagine somebody who
is a journalist probably um
and he's a founding member of the proud
boys they probably know how to get their
message across
they probably know how to target that's
crazy because isn't vice hyperliberal
no so that's the thing after he got
pushed out they started exposing these
alt-right groups and all of that right
so he's no longer with vice okay yeah
he's just one of the original
co-founders of it
yeah that so that's crazy to me
that somebody who yeah a platform that's
uh
really progressive and and somewhat
liberal uh
that that is what it's recognized for at
this point but yet one of the
co-founders was
that's a scary thing too where i i think
when i look at somebody
like president trump who doesn't
understand the power of his words
he doesn't understand the the ripple
effect that he has when he says things
like the way that he does
and he doesn't unders he doesn't take on
that personal responsibility
and for people who don't understand it
and don't get that and don't think that
that's an issue
i want to know what's like to be in your
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] head
i actually think the opposite i think he
knows exactly
he just doesn't give a [ __ ] that's how
morally bankrupt he is
he knows but he doesn't give a [ __ ]
because like in that case when he was
just like stand back
when he said what uh stand back and
stand by yeah i feel like he just
was blabbing and he says something like
that and in his mind he doesn't even
understand the ripple effect that that
happened oh right and that
yeah like that that type of moment and i
don't want somebody like that to lead
this country for sure
that's an issue that i have policies
aside it's like
for example when he says something like
china virus right and the argument
behind that it goes well it's a virus
that came from china right
but once again as as rudimentary and
dumb as
dumb people are they don't ever want to
think about context
and it's weird how they can only apply
context to their personal life but they
can't see it for others it's
so hypocritical it's unreal right and
i'll get to a point where i'll use an
example for that later but
when when when he said something like
china virus
it was known that there was a spike in a
lot of racial attacks towards asian
people
because of this thing i mean just in new
york there was somebody who was lit
on [ __ ] fire yeah right and this
stuff starts stems from a place of
of improper rhetoric used by the leader
of our country right and because
maybe he does understand or doesn't
understand that at all
i can't back somebody who doesn't get
that right
and even for a personal level as an
asian american when you do that type of
stuff like for example
i was living in south pasadena for the
longest [ __ ] time
i've never had a single moment
of racism towards me
the moment he said that within the next
month i've had people giving me some of
the dirtiest looks yeah
and i'm like what in the what world am i
in right now
so it honestly gave like a green light
to a lot of people who
had these ill feelings towards people of
color whether it was asian or not
and it's like it's almost like the
president is saying that gave them this
like
fire of like oh well if he says it i
guess i could say it too
because he won't understand the personal
responsibility that he has
in creating such a negative outlook on
americans in this country
is partially a big part of the reason
why i can't back somebody like that
once again policies aside and people
don't want to see
and they can't see that when all you
have to do is apply that to your
personal life
and understand that yeah the facts are
facts but you have to understand that
there is
a cause and effect to the stuff that you
say right like for example let's just
say this
um andrew you have a uh a really close
friend of yours right
uh recently passed away right but this
person was
sick you do it i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
this person is uh 600 pounds yeah right
and then we're at the funeral right and
i look at you and i go well
if your fat [ __ ] friend didn't eat
himself that he probably would he or she
would probably still be alive
what i'm saying is really true these are
facts
but i'm not looking at context where i'm
saying it and the ripple effect that it
has on you or how it makes you feel
right right and so if i apply that in my
personal life why can't i apply that to
the present of the [ __ ] united states
i i don't understand why people can't do
that
it's a very simple concept again because
they're
they're they're not thinking about it
that way they don't want to open their
mind to that they don't want
to to look at reality or facts
they want to just be stuck in their
beliefs because
they feel good about it for whatever it
empowers them in whatever shape or form
um and and a lot of the message that
would come out of trump's mouth is
promoting
hate instilling fear in people when you
say the china virus
what does that do it makes people
fearful of
one asian people right because let's be
real they're not going to be able to
distinguish
between a chinese everyone's a [ __ ]
right
two you're promoting violence as well
because you're you're talking about it
in such a negative like these are the
people to blame
you know that's where it came from you
know the china var and
look the media uh the news
correspondents
like they'll be there and they'll say
like don't you think if you say the
china virus that that's uh
sending the wrong message or what is the
china very what do you want me what do
you want me to do it came from china
like so he knows the reasons of why he
shouldn't say it
he doesn't give a [ __ ] though because
he's dumb he just doubles down
he doubles down whenever somebody's
critical of him
he argues with um
lies and doubles down on his stance
whatever whatever its stance it may be
and i you know listen i gotta be smart
about my [ __ ] too for the longest time
too when i when i saw that tweet of
somebody who was in
the white house and they overheard
somebody calling uh the
the coleman 19 the kung flu i'll tell
you this
i laughed my ass off i laughed so
[ __ ] hard i was like would you call
it the cub
flute that [ __ ] had me dying laughing
right
but do i want that are president of the
united states to say that right
absolutely not
and and i think that's kind of uh you're
hitting the point on the head right
there
is that this this man
you know this creature
he does not represent in any way shape
or form
somebody who's considered presidential
you don't look at this person and think
wow he is a presidential type of guy you
know
nothing nothing about him makes you
think
this guy's president especially when you
compare it to all the presidents that
have existed
you know well i mean i guess george w
bush is more kind of like your everyday
man type of people
or person and that's why a lot of people
related to him i mean he had he had a
lot of his
gaffes too when he was talking publicly
you got to put food
on your family i was like this
[ __ ] said what
what did he say no but but i mean
contrary to what his public persona was
like i mean
people have said this guy's actually
very intelligent
you know uh but that that's that's
besides the point what i'm saying is
trump you don't look at the guy again
policies and everything aside you don't
look at the guy and think
yeah that is a president i just don't
think he knows what he's doing you know
and it's hard
it's hard for me to back somebody who i
don't agree with on
a lot of things i guess and i i don't
know like i said once again i got a
preface
to say it again i don't know anything
about politics and policy so
in terms of somebody saying to me well
look at what he's done for the economy
of the united states do i i don't know
and i wonder when people say that if
they know either or if they're just
regurgitating stuff
from the party that says that these are
facts and we're not really doing the
research behind
it so i don't really know so all i know
right now is that i'm gonna have to go
with
my morals and choose somebody as a
presidential candidate
that i would like to represent this
country um and that's as far as i'm
going to go for that so
you know basically this whole podcast is
i'm endorsing biden
you know what you know what though i'm a
registered reporter by the way
i did crack up during the debate though
when uh
biden was trying to talk and uh he was
trying to make points by
starting from one right yeah he's like
one blah blah blah and trump kept
interrupting him
and then he's had two and then trump
interrupted him again
and then i think he forgot he gets so
distracted that he was on point number
two and he went to three and then he
started
naming some points and trump goes you're
actually on two by the way
i was like okay that that's pretty funny
man
cause like trump was interrupting you
interrupting him like saying all this
[ __ ] he goes oh
actually you're on you're on number two
by the way another thing that concern
that concerns me about biden
but uh not even heard um during a speech
biden talked about when he had
i think it was during his vice
presidency where he actually had to go
through like brain surgery
you know so it's like [ __ ] man
well the age factor is definitely
something well i think he's turning like
3072 in about a month
this was [ __ ] hella old man not to
mention i think
um i i've read that he used to have a
stuttering problem too
uh and so like you know public speaking
is obviously something he had to work on
right um but yeah sleepy joe sleepy
yeah that's one thing i'll give trump
credit for it's a funny nickname man
definitely just be roasting people
call him super joe but uh yeah that's
that's why it's like ah you know [ __ ]
this guy trump
and everything he stands for but then
you got somebody else who
you don't feel confident in like their
uh
their mental state and their mental
abilities at this point in their life
it's like this dude
seems like he got one foot out the door
already you know what i mean
um and look i don't some of the
like speaking mishaps that he's had
through the campaigning process
i don't know if that is uh because of
age
or or well age in terms of his mind
deteriorating or or like he just
can't handle the whole campaigning
process anymore so he's just like tired
i forgot it was a clip of him coming up
and he goes we're over here at the
something something community center and
he was like no we're not
that's where i used to internet when i
was younger it's right across the street
but you guys know what i'm talking about
i was
that's what i'm saying is that a result
of like his mind just breaking down
because of
age or because he's just tired and he
can't handle that type of stuff and he's
like kind of delusional he's gonna be in
his 80s by the time he's done
yeah just nuts yeah how how is trump
like is he in his 70s
yeah he's in the 70s they're both in
their 70s yeah trump is just in the
younger side of 70s and uh he looks like
[ __ ] too
oh yeah i mean he's i i call him the
orange buffoon
the orange buffoon he he looks like he
looks like a brown paper bag
filled with cheese looks like leather
with a hay stack on top
you know dude if joe biden could wrote
there's so many things joe biden can
roast that full about i'm like dude i
wish they would have just bought a bat
a battle rapper to write him disses and
that [ __ ] would have been [ __ ]
hilarious speaking of disses though
man the low blow of like trump attacking
biden's son i mean yeah joe initially
thought he was going after beau
uh who who passed away right and he
served in the military
but then uh and then so like biden goes
off on this
spiel about like you know how dare you
attack him like he was
he was uh you know um a hero military
hero served honorably all that
and then trump just stops him and
corrects him i'm talking about hunter
and i'm like oh that's still a [ __ ]
low blow dude
yeah and then and then like look man i
respect
uh biden for just getting real in that
moment talking about how um
his son had drug problems yeah you know
uh
and and like addressed it as like um
this is a common problem
like that that other americans are going
through and and my son went through it
and but like even still like the fact
that he had to
address that you know because trump
decided to take a low blow out
i mean the weird thing is like trump you
can't you can't address anybody's flaws
like you you're not in that moral
position or moral high ground to do
anything like that
yeah you got to take a look at yourself
first so it's like even even when he
said that i'm like who the [ __ ] are you
talking about dude
when he has narcissistic tendencies
it's impossible for him to do that yeah
you know he doesn't ever look at himself
and and uh in a critical light yeah he
probably looks at it from
looks at himself thinking he's the
biggest and best of everything
probably the smartest the most smartest
the wealthiest
the best at everything you know and look
you you see that when he talks
likes like you've never seen before it's
gonna be the biggest
the best you won't even believe it it's
going to be huge
yeah huge like human trash
human
human trash that guy human trash
for those of you that don't know look up
apollo costa talking [ __ ] against the
israelite sonia ufc fighters
you've been drinking human trash well
guys that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast we usually don't
talk about politics but that
presidential debate was [ __ ]
hilarious like it was
it was just honestly hard to get through
yeah more than politics i think we just
talked about like
yeah the sheer ridiculousness of this
country just kind of like social
media that we're in we just have the
beast we all just have to be
individually a lot smarter you know like
i'm saying
i'm i'm saying this stuff about myself
too i get hyped up about these quick
little articles and it puts me into a
crazy emotional state and i haven't even
done the research so
it's what it is man well you guys if
there's any topics you guys want us to
talk about or you guys have any personal
issues that you want us to address on
the podcast
anything is up for grabs that's
geniusbrainpodcast gmail.com you can
find edric
at ed2 on instagram also check out the
clothing brand secret society that's
e t s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y dot com and uh
first time
customers use the code brain 15 to get
15
off your first purchase yes 15 of fat
deals baby
and uh yeah every sundays and thursdays
you will see a genius brain podcast and
we will see you all next time
oh that's right
that presentation debate was nuts yeah
as is the most ridiculous
debate i've ever seen man but look i'm
looking forward to